(zooming)
- What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan, my one word is believe
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
I started the Did You Know series
to try to get to know some of
the successful entrepreneurs
we've profiled in a little
bit more personal way.
Share some surprising facts about them
that maybe you don't know yet
and give you a little bit of a inside peek
into their lives and who they are.
So today we're going to
learn nine surprising facts
about Oprah Winfrey.
(theme music)
(bell rings)
Fact number one, her
original name was Orpah
after the biblical character
in the Book of Ruth
and her aunt named her that.
It's on her birth certificate,
but so many people mispronounced
it and called her Oprah
that eventually the name just stuck.
- I was born, as I said, in
rural Mississippi in 1954
and I was born at home
and there were not a lot
of educated people around
and my name had been
chosen from the Bible.
My Aunt Ida had chosen the name,
but nobody really knew how to spell it
so it went down as Orpah
on my birth certificate
but people didn't know
how to pronounce it.
So they put the P before
the R in every place else
other than the birth certificate.
So on the birth certificate it is Orpah
but then it got translated
to Oprah and so here we are
but that's great because
Oprah spells Harpo backwards.
I don't know what Orpah spells.
(bell rings)
- Fact number two, 50 Cent
named his dog Oprah after her
and his cat after her best friend, Gail.
- Let me ask you, I heard
you have a dog named Oprah?
- Yes.
- I consider that a compliment,
whether you meant it to be one or not.
- Yeah, I love her, I love you.
(Oprah laughs)
You know when then say a
dog's a man's best friend?
- Yeah, I know, I've
had 22 dogs in my life.
I have five right now.
Okay, but you named your dog Oprah,
that was not the compliment.
- I added a cat, I got a cat too.
- [Oprah] Name?
- Gail.
(Oprah laughs)
You know I was just lookin'
for a real cute names for the pets
that people would--
- Do you still have the dog named Oprah?
- Yeah, I got a babysitter
for her when I travel.
- Wow, you have a dog nanny.
I call it dog nanny.
- Dog nanny.
- Okay, why'd you name your dog Oprah?
- At the time I was just
looking at the situation
and saw I was developin' negative feelings
for someone who doesn't even know me.
- Yeah.
- And then I gave it to the dog
cause I was excited about
the dog at the time.
- So now do you have
greater affection for me.
- Absolutely, I have for
you for a few years now.
I take pictures and say
crazy stuff on Twitter
but people impact because
they would associate it to me
saying it to you.
- I know.
(bell rings)
- Fact number three, she helped
to launch Doctor Phil's career.
- I feel like I raised this dude.
And let me just tell ya,
I had a moment driving in
and seeing your big face
on the side of the Paramount wall.
I must say wow!
(audience applause)
Wow, wow!
And it all started cause we going through,
I was going through a hard time.
- What was it, 98?
- It was 98.
- And we worked for two years before that.
- [Oprah] That's right.
- So we been knowin' each other 20 years.
- No, I was knowing,
Jay was in high school.
- Cause I remember Jay,
came time for you to testify
and you said not unless Jay's here.
- Jay's here, yeah.
- She called Jay's high school
and said I need him out of class
and the principal went
to his class and said
"Somebody that sounded a
whole lot like Oprah Winfrey."
- Like Oprah Winfrey.
(audience laughs)
- "Just called and said
they need Jay out of class."
- You know what it was,
cause Jay and I became friends
and I just wanted
somebody to hold my hand.
So we did that trial
and then I said to Phil,
I wanted you to come on television
and do for the other people
what you had done for me.
(bell rings)
- Fact number four, she once
competed in Miss Black America.
- I remember back in 19 blah
blah, when I was a contestant,
that I just was so
excited about being there.
I considered it a major
accomplishment just to get there
and represent my state, Tennessee.
And I remember being so nervous and upset
when all the girls,
at least I thought all the girls,
at least appeared to be all the girls,
got flowers from home
from their boyfriends
and I was dating this dud at the time
who did not send me not even
one single solitary rose
and I remember being so upset about it
and it was Miss Iowa who said to me
"It really doesn't matter if
you put a flower on your mind."
And so I let that kind of
carry me through the contest
having that flower in my mind
and believing anything was possible
and just enjoying the experience.
And although I didn't place,
I went home with a flower in
my mind feelin' pretty good.
(bell rings)
- Fact number five is
she considered starting
a girls school in Africa
to be one of her greatest accomplishments.
- As a mother, as just a person who
has been a part of your lives
for the past four, five years,
I've never been more proud.
I think you all were exemplary.
You made me a really proud Momma.
- [Juju] She may not
have biological children,
but thanks to the first graduates
of the Oprah Winfrey
Leadership Academy for Girls,
Oprah says she now understands
the trials and tribulations,
as well as the joys, of parenthood.
- Nice to see you!
- All seen in the documentary
The First Graduating Class.
So when they call you Mom
Oprah, that's for real.
- Juju, if you were there
more than 10 minutes,
they'd call you Sis Juju.
- No matter who you're with,
no matter what you're doing,
if one of these girls calls,
you pick up the phone.
- Oh yes, now we're all
texting all the time.
As a matter of fact that
just happened this morning
and I was on the phone
last night for an hour
with one of 'em trying
to watch the debate.
(Juju laughs)
I was like okay, trying
to watch the debate
but okay I hear what you're saying.
Yes, I think I've come
into my mothering space
in a way that was wholly,
wholly so unexpected.
I knew from the moment
that I met these girls
that I was going to fall in
love with them and I did.
- [Juju] The maternal
bonding began five years ago
as a leap of philanthropic faith,
inspired by the venerable Nelson Mandela.
- What is the single life changing,
trajectory changing moment for me
was being exposed to a world of education
that offered me a new insight
into how I saw the world.
So I just wanted to do that
for somebody else, that's all.
(bell rings)
- Fact number six, she
started going to school
at the age of six,
already knew how to read
and was consistently
ahead of her classmates.
- First day I went to
school, I was in a classroom,
by the time I was six years old,
didn't go to school
till I was six years old
cause I was living with my
Grandmother at that time.
But she had taught me how
to read, read the Bible,
Bible stories.
So I went into the
classroom knowing Nicodemus,
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego,
I could spell all of those words.
I thought I was preachin'
to my kindergarten teacher.
So she was like who is this girl?
So I was never placed in an environment
where I was ever made to feel inferior.
I always felt like I'm the
smartest kid in this room.
And because I was never placed,
never put in a position where
I was made to feel less than,
I didn't grow up feeling
less than, you know?
- And the rest as they say is history.
- And the rest they say is history.
And it's all about what you believe.
You know I say this too,
when I do something on my
network now called Life Class.
The fundamental key to
success is what you believe
is true for yourself.
Not what you want, not what you desire.
It's what do you believe.
You can say I want to be
the most successful person
in the world,
but if you believe that
there's a glass ceiling
and you're going to have a hard time
kicking through that glass ceiling,
you will be defined by the glass ceiling.
And the great beauty and gift of my life
is that I was never defined by the box
that other people tried to put me in.
(bell rings)
- Fact number seven, in 2011 she received
an honorary Oscar for her
philanthropic efforts.
- It's unimaginable that I
would be standing before you
voted by the Board of Governors.
(audience applause)
- [Announcer] Drama at the
Governors Awards as Oprah Winfrey
accepted the Jean Hersholt's
Humanitarian Award
from the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences.
- I don't know of anyone, anyone,
who would be more deserving.
- What this really means
is that all of us can make
a difference through
the life that we live.
- [Announcer] Oprah, Oscar
nominated for The Color Purple,
was honored for her philanthropy.
- She's always thinking about
how she can help others.
- Increasing the literacy
level of this country
by your mere passion for books.
(bell rings)
- Fact number eight, she ran
the Marine Corp. Marathon
with her trainer, Bob Green.
- I vowed that I was
going to run a marathon
even though I was all
blowed up at the time.
Agreed?
(audience laughs)
That I was going to work on myself
and I was going to run a
marathon by the time I turned 40.
Well it was my biggest dream ever
and for months, for months
you know you have to train
so that you can handle the 26 miles.
Here's some of the training.
Okay, so this is August 9th
and we're about eight and a
half miles into a 15 mile run.
All a part of the training
for the 26 mile marathon.
I've been running now for
exactly two hours straight.
Exactly.
I had to stop to wee
willy winkle four times.
It's a bad willy winkle day for me.
(barking)
Bob just said "Hey, got
some good news for ya.
"After today you only
have 10 more long runs
"like this one till the marathon."
(laughing)
He calls that good news!
I'm ready to die and you
think that's good news!
(laughing)
Don't tell me no bad news okay.
Okay, so that was just
a part of the training.
Two weeks ago I ran the
Marine Corps Marathon
in Washington D.C. and
this was the real deal.
We got to the race site about
an hour before the start time.
It was pouring rain.
Hadn't expected that.
As I made my way to the start
I was feeling a little
nervous really, anxious
and a lot of pressure
as all the photographers surrounded us.
- [Man] Alright guys, give me a path here.
Move it!
- [Oprah] I was thinking what
have I gotten myself into?
I finally made it through the crowds.
Their spirit hadn't been
dampened at all by the downpour.
- [Woman] Good luck Oprah!
- Yeah! Thanks!
And then I got my last
little good luck hug in
and tried to calm myself as
the national anthem played.
(applause)
I was really anxious to get going.
The starting gun sounded,
15,000 runners took off at once.
I knew they were going to
swallow me and they did.
I was swallowed by the massive pack
of all those marathoners.
About 37 minutes into the run,
I looked at my watch
and said remember this
cause you're feeling pretty good.
Two tabloid reporters were so
dead set on getting the scoop
on my first marathon they
actually ran the race
alongside me.
This is David from the National Enquirer.
Peter ran the whole way for 13 miles.
- I'm still here!
- David came to meet us back there.
This was my worst nightmare.
I had to pee and there's
the National Enquirer
running next to me.
At mile 16 I'd been running
for almost three hours.
We rounded the Capital, I
was feeling pretty good.
As you can see the rain wasn't letting up.
Miles 19 through 21,
whoa, those were tough!
Lots of runners were dropping out,
slowing down, walking,
just too tired go on.
I'd been running at that point
for about over four hours
and I was starting to hurt.
The crowd was great.
As I was nearing the final few miles,
the momentum of the
crowd helped to carry me
to the finish line.
(crowd cheering)
People always said it
would feel like this.
And it was the greatest feeling
I believe I've ever had.
I started to cry when I
saw that 26 mile marker
and realized my dream
had really come true.
I did it!
I did it.
I actually run a full marathon.
(bell rings)
- And fact number nine,
for a period of time
she sang the theme song for her own show.
♫ Ohhhh, run on, run on
♫ Run on, run on
♫ I believe I run on
♫ See what the end will be
♫ Believe I work on
♫ Find out what waits for me
♫ I see 10,000 stories
and glories and dreams
♫ See angles right here on Earth
♫ I see laughing and growing and loving
♫ And knowing what life is worth
♫ So I believe I run on
♫ And see what tomorrow will be
♫ Run on, run on
♫ Cause I like what I see
♫ Come on and run with me
♫ Run on, run on
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video?
Did you learn something new about Oprah
that you didn't know before?
How many of the nine surprising
facts did you not know?
I'd love to hear from it.
Share it down in the comments below.
Also is there something we missed?
Is there a number 10, number 11
that you want to add to the list
that people may not know?
I'm really curious to find out.
Share that in the comments too.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(zooming)